let's go to the phone lines at (617) 830-4750
many people wanting to get on today.
Let's start with our caller from the nine
seven one area code.
Who is calling today from nine seven one
uh, my name is Michael from the Portland,
Oregon area.
Hey Michael, what's going on?
Hey man, I just wanted to, first of all, thanks
a lot for taking did my call.
I just wanted to share my opinion on which
democratic, uh, candidate has the best chance
of beating Trump.
Okay.
And just so we understand, is this an opinion?
Is this a qualitative or quantitative opinion?
Uh, I guess it's just, it's just simply my
opinion.
Qualitative.
It's not based on any kind of data.
In other words, it's based on your sense of
what's going on.
Yes, exactly.
Got it.
Okay.
So I think that, uh, the country, the people
of this country have been looking for some
sort of major shift and major change in who
it is that we elect as president Obama was
obviously the first person that, um, rally
change and a lot of people got behind that.
And I think that simply just carried over
into Donald Trump, um, with people searching
for something outside of the standard lifetime
politician.
Uh, I was a huge Bernie supporter last election,
donated to his campaign multiple times.
Uh, but I don't even for half a moment I think
that he has a chance of winning this go around.
Yeah.
Simply because he's, I mean, he's been made
to look like a radical to anyone on the right.
Um, there's always like a, like a talking
line that, you know, what is the housewife
in Kansas?
Think about such and such candidate.
And my wife's family's from Kansas and I talked
to a lot of Kansas and Iowa people.
And, um, it just seems like, you know, Bernie
Sanders has been made to seem like a radical
plus with his heart attack.
I don't, you know, his health was already
a concern.
You even, you know, I think his supporters,
um,
no, let me just interject one here.
Michael.
Let's assume you're right and that Bernie
does not appeal to Kansas Housewives and thus
he wouldn't win in Kansas.
And let's assume he wouldn't win against Trump
in Iowa.
He doesn't need to win in either of those
States.
Right.
So it seems like that's maybe not part of
your analysis.
Well, I think part of it too is just being
able to sway voters who may have, you know,
a vote voted for Obama originally and then
those who shifted over to Trump.
Um, I don't think Bernie has the ability to
really shift them back over to voting for
a Democrat.
Okay.
And I getting to the candidate that I think
does, I think the only candidate to have the
chance of doing that is Andrew yet.
Oh boy.
And why, why do you think that he can't seem
to get past 3.5% nationally?
What do you think is holding him back?
If he is someone who is going to just overwhelm
voters with his policy and and everything,
why, why is he getting more support?
Well, I think it starts with has to do a lot
with the polling.
Uh, you know, a lot of the people to answer
poll phone calls are elderly.
They're staying at home there.
That's pretty, that's been pretty widely debunked.
Michael, I think you should take a look at
the methodology.
So now I do have to stop you.
There was a poll from CNN from a while ago
that oversampled landlines, but we've done
a deep dive into this and for the most part
the polls are adjusting the sample on the
basis of uh, what populations are empirically
more likely to vote, uh, and or the portion
of the population that those popular, those
demographics represent.
So I think to write off the polling is oversampling
elderly as the reason why Andrew Yang isn't
doing well would be, if that's your argument
then isn't Bernie also probably doing better
than the polls say?
But you're saying Bernie has no chance?
Well let me say, obviously I'm wrong cause
you pointed that out.
So thank you for educating me on that.
I think that's part of it.
Um, I think another part of the reason why
Andrew Yang isn't pulling as well as the same
reason why Bernie Sanders wasn't pulling as
well last election.
Right?
Like he wasn't getting the air time, he wasn't
getting the fair questions.
Uh, you know, when they spoke to him they
were asking kind of ridiculous questions about
Trump.
Do you see the same kind of things happen
more and more, uh, Andrew gangs is getting,
you know, better questions about his policy.
Yeah.
But even despite that, back in 2016, even
if I grant that Bernie was not treated fairly
in 2016 I, I agree with you, didn't he still
get to polling like 35% in the primary?
Whereas if we apply the same thing, Andrew
Yang doesn't seem to be getting past three
or 4%.
I'm just trying to look at the facts.
Right?
I like Andrew Yang.
I've had him on the show.
I have no problem with them personally.
But to say that it's the same thing as with
Bernie, despite all that, Bernie still got
to close to 40% the democratic primary last
time around,
right?
Yeah.
No, absolutely.
But how many people were in the field last
time?
There was no question.
It was a different race.
Listen, Michael, I do, I want to get onto
some other people, but let me ask you this.
Do you think Andrew Yang will ultimately be
the nominee?
Okay.
No,
you don't.
Okay.
Neither do I.
No, and I, and I don't think, and I, and it
pains me to say this and I felt this way last
election.
I said, if Bernie Sanders doesn't win the
nomination for the Democrats and Trump is
gonna win.
And I think that way about Andrew Young this
time, I don't, I think if Andrew Yang isn't
the one to go against Trump, I think the Democrats
are going to lose again.
All right.
Thank you so much for the call.
A prediction that a, you are not alone in
making.